[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
welcome welcome welcome to the Tony
Michaels podcast
Thursday November 17th Nancy Pelosi is
taken to the floor of the House
Representatives
he's going to speak it appears she's
going to speak about what her future
plans are
would you pray with me as the speaker of
the house so we will keep an eye on that
they are praying right now uh in the
house chamber so we will keep an eye on
that uh here uh as Nancy Pelosi speaks
she gaveled in and we will uh continue
to cover this story uh there's a lot of
news this morning out of the House of
Representatives and if you haven't
noticed the um the Republicans are
absolutely controlled by Hunter bodies
laptop it almost seems like there's like
a software glitch
um with the lamped up and they're
absolutely obsessed and cannot think
about anything else
but the lampped up and they're going to
say lamped up as many laptop times as
they laptop can say laptop I mean it's
the laptop Congress now
oh what a [ __ ] show this is gonna be
it's not surprising though that
Republicans are gonna absolutely [ __ ]
destroy what institutions we have left
um this is not a surprise and they're
also threatening to shut down the
government as if that's always been a
really great idea and that's always went
well for them
so we will we will see these [ __ ] show
commence
and now what happens with the speaker of
the house I have no idea uh Nancy Pelosi
is supposed to speak here about what the
Democrats are going to do about their
leadership it seems as if she's going to
um take a a back seat to Hakeem Jeffries
he is the Congressional leader out of
New York uh Queens of Brooklyn let's
let's listen to what's happening on the
floor here things and announces to the
house her approval thereof for someone
to cause one of rule one the journal
stands approved the Pledge of Allegiance
will be led by the gentleman from South
Carolina Mr Wilson okay they're going to
say the Pledge of Allegiance here
um and then we'll we'll keep an eye on
this uh because apparently she's going
to make the speech on the floor
um with her time
as it's designated to her
and then uh it's supposed to be that
she's passing the torch to
um Hakeem Jeffries again he's the
Congressional leader if you haven't
caught any clips of Hakeem Jeffries I
would suggest you go catch some clips
we're gonna watch some clips today one
famous clip where King Jeffries is
absolutely stuffing
Clarence Thomas and his his seditionist
Q Anon wife Jeannie Thomas into a
[ __ ] locker and that is one of the
clips that you will see
um let's go back to the house four and
see what they're talking about here
bipartisan task force to end sexual
violence I've seen how perpetrators of
workplace sexual assault yeah so they're
just talking about the normal business
there keep an eye on it here as we go
and that way you guys can see the
comments from Nancy Pelosi about the
Democratic Leadership in the house now
I'm not surprised that Nancy Pelosi at
this point is taking this opportunity to
take a step back
I mean the the Insurrection is the Q and
honors the right wing Talkers in this
country drove those q and honors
into a friend violent frenzy to one of
them broke into her house uh and beat
her husband in the head with a hammer
and then the Republicans uh decided to
make jokes about it if it was funny
stuff and spread bio misinformation of
course that's their MO that's what they
always do
it's a thing that they like is to spread
misinformation and lies
but I want to get back a little bit to
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan and
his obsession with Hunter Biden's laptop
you know Jim if you were just just a
smidge just a just a drop like a
peppering of concern about I don't know
college students
that were being sexually assaulted at
the University you worked at as you are
about Hunter Biden's laptop
maybe just maybe people wouldn't [ __ ]
think you're such a vile piece of [ __ ]
oh yeah and get a [ __ ] jacket for
crying out loud it's Congress man it's
Congress even John fetterman put on a
[ __ ] jacket dude
really come on give it the jacket let's
let's go let's let's act like we're
serious here
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan and
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] listen
this is going to be
the biggest list
of of [ __ ] for Democrats to run
against
and I say that because this is the
opportunity that we need for a national
narrative
and the national narrative that we just
had in the midterm of why you don't put
these [ __ ] Kooks in charge of
anything
they literally are going to I I
predicted this that you're going to say
the word [ __ ] laptop into the
official record at least 2 000 times in
the first 60 days
when this new Congress is sworn in
foreign
doubt me on that
they're gonna say the word laptop
any time they can get a laptop chance to
say the word laptop on the laptop floor
of the laptop House Representatives
laptop laptop laptop like they're just
gonna try to get it into the record and
beat it into America's brains
here's the good news that [ __ ] doesn't
work
it doesn't work
it didn't work in the midterm people
didn't buy that [ __ ] oh well but but
they won the house arrest they're gonna
win the house by maybe two seats three
if they're [ __ ] lucky
they didn't win the house it's basically
a [ __ ] tie
for all intense purposes
and really shutting down the government
and only talking about Hunter Biden's
laptop and Joe Biden leaving Afghanistan
a war that we were in for 20 years and
the American people were ready to
[ __ ] leave that behind us by the way
a lot of Americans didn't even [ __ ]
know we were still in Afghanistan that's
how long it been
do you really believe that every single
American believed that we were still at
war with in Afghanistan when Joe Biden
implemented Trump's bone-headed plan to
leave Afghanistan you really think
that's
a thing no a lot of Americans had no
[ __ ] idea
there's Americans out there that think
JFK Jr is still alive
they think Michael Jackson's alive and
he's gonna run with Donald Trump in
2024.
and somehow that's gonna help their side
I I don't know how the [ __ ] are you
supposed to keep up with this [ __ ]
and it's all at a time
where Donald Trump is gonna [ __ ] all
over the Republican Party
so not only are they going to take
control of the House of Representatives
and absolutely [ __ ] that place up
they're gonna destroy it
they're going to destroy Appropriations
by [ __ ] shutting down government for
God knows how long and God knows how
many times
they can't govern where the [ __ ]
so who knows even if they know how to
shut down government even
how the [ __ ] are we even gonna tell
but their goal their goal is to bang up
Appropriations
oh we're gonna We're Not Gonna fund
Ukraine we want Putin to win oh yeah
great message
great National narrative to support an
authoritarian hmm
it's almost like the American people
just refudiated your authoritarianism
and you're flirting with dictators it's
almost like that happened it's kind of
like in Pennsylvania
Michigan Wisconsin Arizona
[Music]
and soon to be in Georgia
the American people told you to [ __ ] off
with your nonsense in swing States
that's really the biggest message here
and we've been talking about that the
seats that were most important were
those governors and Secretary of State
because even if Democrats win or could
win the House Representatives by one
maybe two seats you think shit's gonna
get done
it's gonna be really [ __ ] difficult
really difficult to get anything done
here's the good news
and here's why we need to lean into this
race in Georgia
you know the one where
CTE gay
[ __ ] that
guy who would try to kill his wife or
some [ __ ] do you see this new tape God
damn he's [ __ ] talking about killing
his wife again in another [ __ ] video
Herschel Walker
when we absolutely dunk him in the trash
and send Warnock back to the Senate we
have 51. not only does that give the
Senate more subpoena power but the most
important thing is is we get to Ram
judges down their [ __ ] throats
that's right that's how we're gonna say
it too [ __ ] them we get to Ram judges
all the way down their [ __ ] throats
[ __ ] these sons of [ __ ]
just and it's Mitch McConnell's fault
it's Republicans fault they did this
they made sure that you could just with
50 51 votes you can just do whatever you
wanted with judges that they made sure
of that so I say we take full advantage
and we make sure we pack the [ __ ]
courts just absolutely pack them with
the craziest [ __ ] socialist yeah
let's get communist in there [ __ ] yeah
let's do that
piss on them
piss on them
let's really bang them up
that's what they like to do of course
you know again Joe Biden's gonna pick
[ __ ] nominees that actually have
earned a spot on the judicial bench the
Federal Judicial bench I mean that's
things gonna happen
you know it's not gonna be like [ __ ]
Trump candidates where they can't work
their way out of a wet paper sack
these [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
I mean that's the reality of it but the
other reality is is when we lean into
this race and we when Warnock wins we
get to jam every single [ __ ] one of
these judges
right up their ass [ __ ] them
they can't say [ __ ] they can't do [ __ ]
either
especially if we get that 6 or 51 vote
we got subpoena power
and there's some talk that that Select
Committee in the house can be kind of
transferred I'm not sure exactly the
procedure in this now but the select
committee can be made into a senate
committee I I don't know that that I
have no idea I quite honest I I don't
know of that procedure
um to make the house select committee
into a senate select committee it's a
possibility I guess but that sounds
far-fetched to me
I say just open up a an investigative
body in the Senate investigate every
single [ __ ] one of their laptops
Jared Kushner Ivanka uh let's do Stephen
Miller's lamp top
um I don't know whatever laptop Mark
Meadows [ __ ] them any left Steve Bannon
Roger Stone let's do all the laptops I
mean they don't have to be government
officials
so it's just all the laptops the Senate
laptop committee can investigate all the
laptops that the laptops have in the
laptop area
literally this is how it's going to
sound I'm not [ __ ] you
this is exactly how it's going to sound
in the house laptop laptop laptop laptop
I mean I wouldn't I would bet uh Michael
guessed it here in Mississippi
Republicans speaking on Laura now he
probably said the word labbed up at
least twice in that speech
I don't know
but I'm sure he did
this is what we got to look forward to
and this is why it's so important that
we stay engaged in democracy we can't
let up on these [ __ ] we have to
continue to spread the narrative
that these [ __ ] Republicans don't
want to do [ __ ]
they don't want to do anything and the
reason why is because they can't
they can't do anything
because they don't have any [ __ ]
ideas they don't have any policies
they're like ah Hunter by the laptop gas
prices inflation well what are you gonna
do about it Hunter Biden's laptop gas
prices inflation
like okay well what's the policy friend
Hunter Biden's laptop
gas prices inflation
you're just a [ __ ] broken record
they have no clue what they're doing
they don't have a [ __ ] idea
the one reason why is because they're
base that elected them to these seats
how they gerrymandered it or a bunch of
boneheads who in the [ __ ]
who wants their Congress person to be
representative of them would elect
Marjorie Taylor green look Marjorie
Taylor green is a shitbox
she's a know-nothing a dummy
but the people in her District are more
way way more of the problem than she is
and it's really not the people
necessarily I mean human beings are
[ __ ] trash anyways I mean like can we
all agree on that pretty much
I mean it's it's difficult to really in
this day and age to say that humans just
aren't [ __ ] trash but here's the
thing
it's it's the [ __ ] education that
these people don't get
they don't understand it
literally this lady was talking about
Jewish space lasers
and that everything's a [ __ ] false
flag everything everything's a [ __ ]
false flag
I everything all of it you name it it's
a conspiracy theory and it's a false
flag and they're like yeah that will go
with that because government
what
that's what they selected
but it's not surprising is it really
[ __ ] that surprising that these
people are so detached from reality
that they can't even figure out what
government even is we talked about this
with Texas poll on Tuesday because we
talked about rural areas versus
cities urban areas and higher population
centers right the reason why
that in big cities it seems like a
liberals control things there's a reason
for that
it's because in big cities and bigger
urban areas they have to govern they do
not have a [ __ ] choice they have to
govern there's way too many people that
count on Services roads stop lights
[ __ ] City Planning
there's too many people that rely on
that [ __ ] for them not to govern so what
ends up happening is people who are good
at governing and want to govern govern
and that ends up being [ __ ] liberals
because conservatives don't give two
shits
and and I say conservative [ __ ]
Loosely uh looks like uh Nancy Pelosi is
going to come to the uh the microphone
here so I may have to turn it over to
her here uh to see what the actual
announcement is of her leadership let's
let's go to the floor here
thank you madam speaker
Madam speaker As We Gather here we stand
on sacred ground the Chamber of the
United States House of Representatives
the heart of American democracy I will
never forget the first time I saw the
capital it was on a cold January day
when I was six years old my father
Thomas D'Alessandro Jr was about to be
sworn in for his fifth term in Congress
representing our beloved hometown of
Baltimore
I was riding in the car with my brothers
and they were thrilled in jumping up and
down and saying to me Nancy no Nancy
look there's the capital and I keep
every time I'd say I don't see any
capital is it a capital A a capital b or
a Capital C
and finally I saw it
a stunning white building with a
magnificent Dome I believed then as I
believe today this is the most beautiful
building in the world because of what it
represents the capital is a temple of
our democracy of our constitution of our
highest ideals on that day
thank you
on that day I stood with my father on
this floor as he took the sacred oath to
support and defend the Constitution of
the United States against all enemies
foreign and domestic
all of us who have served in this house
have taken the hallowed oath of office
and it is the oath that stitches us
together in a long and storied Heritage
colleagues who served before us are all
our colleagues colleagues like Abraham
Lincoln
Daniel Webster Shirley Chisholm
Patsy menk and our beloved John Lewis
personally it binds me as a colleague to
my father a proud New Deal to
congressmen and one of the earliest
Italian Americans to serve in the
Congress
and this is an oath we are Duty bound to
keep and it links us with the highest
aspirations of the ages in this room our
colleagues across history have abolished
slavery granted women the right to vote
establish Social Security and Medicare
offered a hand to the weak care to the
sick education to the young and hope to
the many
indeed it is here under the Gaze of our
patriarch George Washington in the
people's house that we have done the
people's work
my colleagues I stand before you as
Speaker of the House
as a wife a mother a grandmother a
devout Catholic a proud Democrat and a
patriotic American a citizen of the
greatest Republic in the history of the
world
thank you
thank you
which President Lincoln called the last
best Hope on Earth indeed in the words
attributed to another of our colleagues
the legendary Daniel Webster he said
hold on my friends to the constitution
of your country and the government
established under it miracles do not
cluster that which has happened but once
in 6 000 years cannot be expected to
happen often indeed American democracy
is majestic but it is fragile many of us
here have witnessed its first fragility
firsthand tragically in this chamber and
so democracy must be forever defended
from forces that wish it harm
last week the American people spoke and
their voices were raised in defense of
Liberty
of the rule of law and of democracy
itself
thank you
with these elections the people stood in
the breach and repelled The Assault on
Democracy they were soundedly rejected
violence and Insurrection and in doing
so
gave proof through the night that our
flag was still there
come on
[Applause]
and now we owe to the American people
our very best to deliver on their faith
to Forever reach for the more perfect
union the Glorious Horizon that our
Founders promised
the questions before this Congress and
in this moment are Urgent questions
about the ideals that this house is
charged by the Constitution to preserve
and protect establish justice ensure
domestic tranquility provide for the
common defense promote the general
welfare and secure the blessings of
liberty to ourselves and our posterity
our posterity our children babies born
today will live into the next century
and our decisions will determine their
future for generations to come
while we will have our disagreements on
policy we must remain fully committed to
our shared fundamental mission to hold
strong to our most treasured democratic
ideals to cherish the spark of divinity
in each and every one of us and to
always put our country first and their
Infinite Wisdom
our Founders gave us their kind their
guidance e pluribus unum from anyone
they could not have imagined how large
our country would become or how
different we would be from one another
but they knew we had to be United as one
we the people one country one destiny
has been with great pride in my 35 years
in the house I have seen this body grow
more reflective of our great nation our
beautiful Nation
[Applause]
when I came to the Congress in 1987
there were 12 Democratic women
now they're over 90 and we want more
[Applause]
the new members of our Democratic caucus
will be about 75 percent women people of
color and lgbtq and we have brought more
voices to the decision-making table when
I entered leadership in 2002 there were
eight of us today there are 17 members
of the leadership
when I first came to the floor at six
years old
never would I have thought that someday
I would go from Homemaker to house
speaker in fact I never
in fact I never intended to run for
public office
Mom and Daddy taught us through their
example that public service is a noble
calling and that we all have a
responsibility to help others and our
family my brother Tommy then became
mayor of Baltimore also but as in my in
my privilege to play a part in forging
extraordinary progress for the American
people I have enjoyed working with three
presidents achieving historic
investments in clean energy with
President George Bush
transformative Health Care reform with
President Barack Obama
[Applause]
and forging and forging the future from
infrastructure to health care to climate
action with President Joe Biden
thank you
now we must move boldly into the future
grounded by the principles that have
propelled us this far and open to Fresh
possibilities for the future
teaches us that for everything there is
a season a time for every purpose under
heaven
my friends no matter what title you all
my colleagues have bestowed upon me
speaker leader whip there is no greater
official honor for me than to stand on
this floor and to speak for the people
of San Francisco
this I will continue to do as a member
of the House speaking for the people of
San Francisco serving the great state of
California and defending our
constitution
and with great confidence in our caucus
I will not seek reelection to Democratic
Leadership in the next Congress
for me the hours come for a new
generation to lead the Democratic caucus
that I so deeply respect and I'm
grateful that so many are ready and
willing to shoulder this awesome
responsibility
Madam speaker standing here today I'm
endlessly grateful for all of life's
blessings for my Democratic colleagues
whose courage and commitment with the
support of your families have made many
of these accomplishments possible in
fact could not have been done without
you
for my dear husband Paul who has been my
beloved partner in life in my pillar of
support
thank you we're all grateful for all the
prayers and well wishes as he continues
his recovery thank you so much
[Applause]
darling children Nancy current Christine
Jacqueline Paul and Alexandra and our
grandchildren Alexander and Aslan Liam
Shawn and Ryan Paul and Thomas Bella and
Octavio they are the joys of Our Lives
for whom we um and we are so very very
proud of them and a comfort to us at
this time
thank you
[Applause]
and for my brilliant dedicated and
patriotic staff under the leadership of
Terry McCullough together working
together the finest group of public
servants the house has ever known thank
you all so much
foreign
and again for those who sent me here for
the people of San Francisco for
entrusting me with the high honor of
being their voice in Congress and this
continued work I will strive to honor
the call of the patron saint of our City
Saint Francis
Lord make me an instrument of thy peace
in this house we begin each day with a
prayer and a pledge to the flag and
every day I am in awe of the Majestic
miracle that is American democracy as we
participate in a Hallmark of our
Republic the peaceful orderly transition
from one Congress to the next let us
consider the words of again President
Lincoln spoken during one of America's
Darkest Hours he called upon us to come
together to swell the chorus of the
Union when once again touched as surely
they will be by the better angels of our
nature
that again is the task at hand
a new day is Dawning on the horizon
and I look forward always forward to the
unfolding story of our nation a story of
light and love of patriotism and
progress of many becoming one
and always an unfinished mission to make
the dreams of today the reality of
tomorrow
thank you all may God bless you and your
families and may God bless continue to
bless our veterans and the United States
of America thank you
foreign
so there you have it
Nancy Pelosi the current Speaker of the
House uh passing the torch it seems as
she will not seek uh re-election to the
leadership of the democratic counts
caucus
um now some are saying that Hakeem
Jeffries may take that torch and run
with it there's a few moments in this of
course there was a lot of Storytelling
um in the speech but there's a few
moments the one moment that stood out to
me in particular is when she pointed out
when she came to the house
in 19 I think 87 or 89 there was 12
women 12 in the Democratic house caucus
now there's over 90. and of course the
Democrats stood up and clapped
because that's quite the accomplishment
really and she said there needs to be
more and I I frankly agree with her the
less men we have in Congress the better
this country will run
but here's the thing
if you watch the screen
you saw Democrats stand up and clap at
that moment because it is it's a
historic figure
that's progress
that's actually making Congress more
representative of what our country looks
like
that's the point of Congress and
representation
literally they are called
Representatives
the Republicans [ __ ] didn't stand up
nope
they don't want women in Congress
that would mean progress
that would mean diversity that would
mean actual representation and that is
not what they want
that's the point
the point is that they don't want you to
have representation
they want the representation to look
like me a white dude that's what they
want
I'm not afraid to say it
that's what the [ __ ] they want
it's the only way they're going to press
their white supremacy [ __ ] on us
as if they control the levers of power
they know that the American people are
not gonna buy this [ __ ] for long
if we have a diverse actual
representative Congress that represents
what America looks like
not just not just skin color or gender
but ideas for crying out loud
because really honestly this idea
that we're 50 50 in this country
half of us want democracy we want to
make sure people have
decent wages they want children to start
school at three instead of five they
want to make sure people don't go
[ __ ] broke to get a college degree or
tech tech degree a technical degree if
they need it
to advance in their career they want to
make sure you don't go [ __ ] broke
over a medical bill
they want to make sure the government
isn't ripping you off on [ __ ] student
loans
they want to make sure that corporations
aren't sticking it to you
the other party wants to investigate
Hunter Biden's laptop
and they want to figure out who's going
in what bathrooms
and Who's got what genitalia
that's that's her [ __ ] message
that's the difference you can't convince
me you are so full of [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you think that's half and half in this
country
[ __ ] I keep saying it over and over
again half these [ __ ] mcgaggers
because they're my Gaggers now they're
not magas anymore they're magagas you
gotta change the
the word
[Music]
because we're headed into uh Stupid
season here with uh Grandpa Poopypants
the Cheeto desk you and honor running
for 20 uh present in 2024.
but the majority of the magagas
are liberals
because they want what I just said and
there's only one party interested in
doing anything
as far as policy is concerned about
those things that I just said
only one the other one wants to [ __ ]
shut down the government
that they want to shut down the actual
institution that allows for people to
have representation so that they can
Institute policy
to do the things that they want
like again you know the education thing
you know having decent [ __ ] Health
Care not go broke because of a medical
bill having a decent wage you know all
those things all that [ __ ] retire not
have their [ __ ] Social Security
ripped away from them after they [ __ ]
paid for it for years and years and
years and decades and decades
they want all that [ __ ] that makes them
liberal
yes it does fake game I know you're
gonna hey you [ __ ] liar no go look it
up go look up the [ __ ] word
let's go look that son of a [ __ ] up
what do you think Liberty means you
stupid [ __ ]
you cannot convince me that half the
country believes
that the number one priority of half the
country is to investigate Hunter Biden's
laptop
you were full of [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
are trying to find things so you don't
have to have ideas so you don't have to
have policies because here's the rub
folks the reason why Republicans suck so
bad at government do you want to know
why do you want to know why they suck so
bad at government is because here's the
thing if they come up with a good idea
on how to solve a problem that exists
instead of making up problems
but if they came up with a good idea a
solution for a problem that exists like
I don't know going broke because of a
medical bill
they would have to push liberal ideas
they would have to back liberal policies
liberal doesn't mean socialist liberal
doesn't mean Democrat go look the
[ __ ] word up
that's why they can't do this
they boxed themselves into a corner the
only policy they can Institute
is to take tax cuts on rich people
and we know how far that gets you I mean
you know what you do is what you do is
you give people like Elon Musk
gazillions of government dollars in in
subsidies
for his companies you make him [ __ ]
super rich off welfare it's welfare you
make them super rich off welfare and
then you let the bonehead go buy a huge
Media company and destroy that
[ __ ] oh that's a good idea
oh but we have to give him tax cuts
because you know he's the victim
[ __ ] out of here with this nonsense
they can't even talk about deficits
anymore have you heard one [ __ ]
Republican one just [ __ ] find me one
clip of one Republican saying the word
deficit
just one send it to me I ain't [ __ ]
it send it to me [ __ ] find it
sometime in the last week where
Republicans said the word deficit
one that's elected or are gonna be
elected or gonna be in the new Congress
find me one said the word [ __ ]
deficit
and I would almost bet you that you
can't find one and I would almost bet
that in the first 90 days of this new
Congress
the word laptop will weigh outweigh the
word deficit
[ __ ] Ron Johnson's doing it as we speak
right now in the Senate as we're sitting
here watching the floor of the house Ron
Johnson is questioning Christopher Ray
the FBI director think about this Ron
Johnson has the FBI director in front of
him can ask him anything he wants to for
oversight anything he wants to and Ron
Johnson's aim of questioning has to do
with a private Citizen's [ __ ] laptop
that's where we're at with these [ __ ]
nincompoop Nazis
nincompoops
that's where we're at and that's what
we're gonna be because that's what you
get when you put people who only want to
obstruct
who only want to give away power to
their donors
who only want to save their ass and keep
their power forget the American people
[ __ ] them give them no opportunity
for any kind of leg up [ __ ] them
because you start to give the American
people
the [ __ ] they want the American people
realize that the Republicans really
don't have any good ideas to begin with
How could a republican convince the
American people that they have good
ideas they can't that's why they're like
bathrooms and I want to check genitalia
for sports events and
and drag queens CRT and laptops
oh yeah and gas prices
foreign
oh that's the best they can do and if
you don't believe me just watch fake
game freak the [ __ ] out when I say this
[ __ ] and I you know I pick on fake Gabe
all the time in the Facebook chat but
the reason why is because the dude's a
queuing on her the dude is not Tethered
to reality he's the Trump copy machine
literally he just come here and he says
the stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] that you'll find
on 4-H and like that's his MO
and it's not just because I you know
it's fake game but the point is is that
there's there there is a low percentage
of the population out there but there's
a lot of them out there
saying the same garbage the same
nonsense repeating the same stupid [ __ ]
as if Hunter Biden committing some sort
of tax fraud and being
indicted and imprisoned for it is gonna
[ __ ] disappoint any Democrat what are
you talking about no one no one is lined
up behind in a line at Mar-A-Lago to go
pay 200 hours to get Hunter Biden to
sign a copy of a book
they're stupid bastards lined up paying
money for Don Jr to [ __ ] sign books
at [ __ ] cokehead are you kidding me
and we're gonna sit here and for two
years and [ __ ] Yammer on and on and
on about a laptop you are some dumb
[ __ ] if Hunter Biden committed
crimes [ __ ] him put him in prison I
guess I think it's a really dumb idea to
put non-violent offenders in prison
anyways to be honest I don't you know
but that's another [ __ ] day another
[ __ ] debate but the point is [ __ ]
indict him and prosecute him then
if he [ __ ] committed crimes my guess
is Hunter Biden
is gonna pay tax penalties here that the
investigation show that he might have
misnumbered his taxes maybe
intentionally maybe not
and they're generally don't imprison
people unless it's very malicious tax
fraud I don't know like what's happening
in New York with Alan weissenberg and
the Trump organization
well you can't you can't make this [ __ ]
up
you can't you won't
but this is the [ __ ] intersection
of WrestleMania and real life
that we are in
and we will continue to be in this
until we can get people like fake Aid to
finally pluck their head out of their
ass and realize you are being duped
dummy
you are a dumb [ __ ] and you're
being duped
by people who really are dumber than you
I don't know how that's possible but
it's working out that way
if anyone watched Donald Trump's speech
even just a little bit of it and I
didn't watch the whole thing I watched
maybe 30 minutes of this [ __ ]
this slog that he had down there at
Mar-A-Lago Jesus Christ the people in
the room were [ __ ] begging to get out
of that [ __ ] place they made it into
a fire hazard locking the goddamn doors
making them not go you can't get out
like in glorious bastards type [ __ ] you
know the insane where they [ __ ] set
the thing on fire the point is this if
you watch that [ __ ] if you watch that
speech and thought Oh yeah this is
something new you are part of the
problem
you're part of the problem you're part
of the problem of people
elevating authoritarianism
Not only was it riddle with just a bunch
of nonsense and lies and it didn't make
any [ __ ] sense it didn't seem like he
was connecting any [ __ ] thoughts of
dots of thoughts anywhere but it's the
same old [ __ ] stick
it's the same stupid routine that he has
he didn't even rewrite the son of a
[ __ ] after he got clobbered in the
midterms he got clobbered and the reason
why here you want to know the reason why
former presidents don't go around
endorsing [ __ ] after they lose
into a midterm of the president they
lost to so they don't [ __ ] lose
Donald Trump all he had to do is stay
out of the [ __ ] midterm he just had
to stay out he could have just said I
support all the Republican candidates
because I want the Republican Party
to be back in power or whatever he could
you know some broad [ __ ] stupid thing
that a former president would say
he could have said that and he would not
he would not be taking the [ __ ]
landmines that he's stepping on
everywhere
he's lost his [ __ ] donors the big
donors are telling him to [ __ ] off
they're not going to give him any money
because he's a loser
he lost the popular vote in 2016. he
lost the midterm in 18. he lost the
presidential race in 20 and lost the
[ __ ] lost the [ __ ] Senate
he loses the midterms now because he
stuck his neck out there
again stepping on land mines everywhere
why would anyone want to be a part of
that well dummies do
I guess her masochist I don't know
coming back for a third round of fourth
round of the Kool-Aid [ __ ] I don't know
can you imagine can you imagine at
Jonestown
if half those [ __ ] didn't take
the Kool-Aid watched watched as everyone
[ __ ] died and they're like you know
what maybe we should go ahead and drink
this three times
that would maybe that's a good idea
we're not dealing with the unignorant
they're [ __ ] ignorant as [ __ ] they
don't know how this [ __ ] Works they
don't want to know how it works really
honestly
because their beliefs
are contradictory to reality
they want to believe [ __ ] that's not
real
that would never be real
but that's where we're in
back to the Nancy Pelosi news here where
she has announced that she will not seek
leadership and the other the other
significant news I guess uh there is
that she is going to stay as a
representative of San Francisco and
she's going to represent that District
in California so she's going to remain
uh representative and I'm sure she will
give counsel to whoever takes the
leadership mantles and rather it
actually is Hakeem Jeffries that's what
everyone is saying that's what the um it
sounds like that's what the house caucus
may want
um is a person like a king Jeffries
which to be honest the king Jeffries is
no no person to Fleck with he will
absolutely burn your house down so and I
I actually welcome new leadership
um I think we could do the same thing in
the Senate eventually
especially after 2024
um I I know
that some people do and don't like Chuck
Schumer uh and his Effectiveness or
non-effectiveness
um he's proven with Joe Biden as the
president and Nancy Pelosi as a speaker
to be pretty damn effective uh but you
know that is a debatable point
but again we can't have that as the
national narrative and that's why Nancy
Pelosi is stepping away here I believe
she knows that the national narrative is
not going to support
her is the minority leader again and
then another mounting another challenge
in 2024 to become the speaker again back
and forth back and forth it's just not
going to play well and the national
narrative is working and what I mean by
that is the the pro-democracy party the
pro-democracy people in the country the
Coalition who believes in democracy not
autocracy is working that the rhetoric
The Narrative the pounding the drum
every single day like we do here on the
Tony Michaels podcast every single
weekday two hours Newton Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific it's working
I know some people like oh you only get
a couple people to watch yeah okay okay
friend
go over to all the [ __ ] platforms and
see how many thousands of people are
watching this show
and making sure that the narrative is is
in the form of democracy not autocracy
and then come back and talk to me okay
okay yeah you might you might not like
my form and my fashion and my style I
don't give a [ __ ]
it ain't it ain't about it ain't about
your dumb ass
it's about the country it's about people
out there who want to have a message
delivered to them and figure out a way
to talk to [ __ ] so you don't
have to turn them away because you're
some kind of elite
if you come here and you think I'm some
kind of liberal Elite you are watching
the wrong Channel I don't know what
you're watching
but that is not what happens here
and that is not what needs to happen in
in the pro-democracy coalition
it is not
we need to continue to to lean into
democracy Lean Into The Narrative I'm
telling you gen Z is with us on this
narrative there is no question after
this election I am a hundred percent
convinced that gen Z is is a hundred
percent Behind The Narrative of
pro-democracy Coalition that that is the
most important thing at the top of the
list because everything else falls under
that
everything else falls under democracy
yesterday in the senate in the [ __ ]
Senate Mitch McConnell who is in a
interracial marriage voted against
protecting interracial marriage
is that significant yes it is
significant and the reason why is
because Mitch McConnell is an
authoritarian
Because he believes in his rights not
yours
that's what it says he's not he's not
unaware that he's in an interracial
marriage he's not [ __ ] unaware of
that
he's totally aware of that that fact he
just believes his is better than anyone
else's
because it's him
because he's the powerful one he's the
authoritarian he's the leader
that's why
so hang on tight because we got two full
years of this [ __ ]
the 2022 midterm
is coming to a close and the counts are
about in and the results are going to be
certified that Congress is going to be
sworn in the Senate's going to be sworn
in and we the people
have to be ready
to lean into democracy and fight for it
and fight for it
by engaging in it
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty
that is the one phrase that put this
show on the map
and it's not my phrase I mean I said it
but it's the direction that democracy
needs to go
for equality and equity for every
[ __ ] every one of them
[ __ ] your privilege
and really honestly use your privilege
use it to smash that privilege
you are the best audience in the world I
am happy to see the speech that Nancy
Pelosi give today and I'm excited
I'm excited to be with you in the next
two years in this fight for democracy
we will build a coalition it will get
bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger
we're not going to stop
relentless
we won't Retreat we're not going to let
down
we're going to keep fighting for what's
what is worth fighting for and that is
your Liberty
everybody stick around we're going to be
right back we're going to do shitless
Roundup I want to show you this um this
clip of Ron Johnson's dumbass already
saying the word laptop as many laptop
times as he can say laptop in the laptop
senate committee laptop hearing that
he's having with the laptop FBI director
laptop laptop laptop we'll be right
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
my co-host Gabe Sanchez is joining us
I hope he had a chance to take a peek at
what the speaker said I want to get his
opinion he used to live in San Francisco
SF as he calls it
yeah I guess I'm a boomer I just don't
understand the SF thing yeah he's giving
me [ __ ] about being a boomer what did
you did you catch did you get some of
them I caught a little bit of it I had
some errands I had to run but uh but I
will say like you know she opening the
door for another a new generation
of what do you think of Hakeem Jeffries
if that's the case I mean what do you
think of him I think that if he takes
the torch I I actually I'm all for that
Firebrand yeah he absolutely takes I
mean no [ __ ] off anyone oh no totally I
mean we've seen so many takes where I I
think I think the commonly used phrase
is uh can somebody call the police I'd
like to report a murder yeah uh just
because of the Savage takes that I want
to see a dead body right exactly it
really is that and he does and he does
he does an amazing job he holds he
[ __ ]
he says [ __ ] him right he doesn't really
care you know what you know what is
significant about King Jeffries that I
think sometimes Nancy Pelosi drops the
ball in a little bit is he absolutely
knows every single [ __ ] point like
every [ __ ] point and he's right there
in the moment no ums no ends no all
right I'm not really nope right on the
[ __ ] narrative boom right he
hits the nail on the head every time
here's a here's an example of that this
is him talking uh I think there's a
couple months ago it was in a house uh
meeting and he's absolutely stuffing the
Thomas's Genie Thomas you know the Q and
honor oh yeah no one that they're
completely okay with but they really are
just obsessed with Hunter Biden's laptop
maybe
a cell phone well maybe we should get
her laptop too she was sending emails
man that's true she was sending emails
but let's watch a game Jeffries this is
the person now he's the Congressional
um uh the congressman of the
congressional district of Brooklyn and
Queens I believe I think it's uh the
eighth District maybe the third or
eighth I'm not sure the number uh there
in New York but he represents Brooklyn
and Queens
um but and and he he does it in that
fashion right in this clip here he
really uses that New York style dunking
let's take a listen and if Justice
Thomas really wants to deal with
bullying in America or this problem of
people supposedly unwilling to accept
outcomes that they don't like I've got
some advice for justice Thomas starting
your own home
have a conversation with Jeannie Thomas
she refused to accept the legitimacy of
the 2020 presidential election why
because she didn't like the outcome
and so instead she tried to steal the
election overthrow the United States
government and install a tyrant
that's bullying
that's being unwilling to accept an
outcome because you don't like the
results because the former twice
impeached so-called president of the
United States of America lost
legitimately to Joe Biden how did she
respond instead she said the bidens
should face a Military Tribunal in
Guantanamo Bay
on trumped up charges of sedition
you've got to be kidding me
and lastly let me ask this question of
brother Thomas why are you such a hater
hate on civil rights hate on women's
rights hate on Reproductive Rights hate
on voting rights hate on marital rights
hate on equal protection under the law
hate on liberty and justice for all hate
on free and fair elections why are you
such a hater
and you think you can get away with it
Escape public scrutiny because you think
that shamelessness is your superpower Mr
chairman here's the news flash Mr
chairman from the house Judiciary
Committee
again and truth will be your Kryptonite
no [ __ ] Jeffries that first year I
would I would love that type of fiery
energy because we know that Kevin
McCarthy's like um everyone's so mean to
me um I wear my khakis he's a [ __ ] just
say it he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah look
Kevin McCarthy King Jeffries and King
Jeffries is not a cook obviously no I
mean I would say that he is
he's got bigger balls than most of the
Republican party like like Texas ball
says he probably has to have a
wheelbarrow to haul those Walkers around
probably I mean look let's let's just
admit what it is like the guy's got
[ __ ] a fire and a passion for
democracy right and and he knows he
knows how to deliver it too like you
know I I believe that that Nancy Pelosi
really
um she is a beacon
um of leadership she is she is the
longest serving house woman house uh
female house Speaker she is and really
um she has paved the way for women in
Congress she even alluded to that inner
speech about how when she came there was
12 now there's 90 and of course
Democrats stood up and applauded and
Republicans like where we don't want
women we don't want women we never do
they never even even if it is even for a
group that claims to love women and love
women's bodies by protecting them from
from getting an abortion right
a party that says they love the women
they they love women so much that
they'll stop women from acting on their
own their own self-interests and then go
uh yeah but we're not gonna We're Not
Gonna clap for this woman or anything
she's done that has been Pro in the
feminist kind of movement right or or
Pro just Pro women at all just like
right just like giving them rights you
know that that's a you bring up a funny
Point people I uh were accusing me of
being anti-woman or some [ __ ] uh on
Twitter now I do have to say because I I
uh Keem Jeffries is not a woman he's
clearly not a woman right I don't Matt
Walsh may have to do a whole nother
documentary to figure out if Matt or if
uh if a king Jeffries is or not because
he doesn't clearly know what a world is
he also again doesn't know what a man is
right that's true Matt Walsh right but
here's the thing is King Jeffrey's
clearly isn't a woman but there is one
thing that Hakeem Jeffries
is a staunch supporter of
is women's rights and and I I would bet
that he would go down in flames fighting
for those rights and when you have
someone when you have someone and I
don't care their man
or a woman and they're fighting against
women having rights I will call you
whatever the [ __ ] I want you are if you
if you are racist a bigot a magaga if
you support fascism if you support this
[ __ ] I will call you a [ __ ] I will call
you a [ __ ] I will call you all kinds of
[ __ ] names I do not give a [ __ ]
because because you are a vile human
being I will do that and it's not
because I don't like women it's because
you don't [ __ ] you don't want
women to have rights you don't respect
women that is why I I will I will
I will burn your house to the ground
here's a good example here's a good
example of one of these Coupes
apparently this is uh a lady who goes on
stage with Eric Trump
and and Mike Flynn at these [ __ ] Q
Anon religious things you know what I'm
talking about yeah yeah the cult
Gatherings yeah but this this lady they
think she's a prophet okay
wrong I'm pretty sure there's something
in the Bible talking about uh you know
false prophets whoa whoa easy on the
Bible talk there I'm just saying like
I'm pretty sure there's something that
talks about you're gonna get fake
idolizing a bunch of Bible links he's
gonna start dropping Bible links if he
ain't careful
this is weird [ __ ] it really feels like
to me that this lady is because a lot of
people were like is she drunk and I
really thought that that's a possibility
when I watched it now I said Karen
Christ because he thinks she's a prophet
and this lady is a hundred percent the
lady that goes in the Starbucks and just
starts beating on the counter and
yelling and screaming because the people
behind the counter didn't get her latte
tall whatever the hell spice latte
people get pretty crazy when you take
away the psls baby yeah but then she
starts spouting off like racial epithets
and stuff and all this [ __ ] over a
[ __ ] hey that's what Christ would do
Tony well Christ would freak out over a
PSL order Karen
Christ would but listen to this [ __ ]
lunatic listen to this
they're saying we win and we're taking
your nation
do you actually believe them
do you believe that I have allowed them
to steal your nation
do you believe them actually allowing
them to steal another election
okay I just want to point out again this
is a lady that goes on stage with Eric
Trump and Mike Flynn and goes and they
they they're mind [ __ ] people at like
these Church events these big Church
events these Q Anon church because
there's a q Anon church is what it is
it's a [ __ ] religion they're a cult
they're [ __ ] religious kids why is
she yelling why her eyes closed what
chair is she [ __ ] [ __ ] in is
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] I'm gonna say [ __ ]
right uh is that gold that's surrounded
by her there's a lot of things that
really give me this idea of like the
Antichrist but she she is I think she's
praying though I think that's what this
is she got her eyes closed she's kind of
got her prayers were supposed to be
between you and God well I don't know
I'm just saying when you pray like that
this seems like more of a using this to
benefit yourself
not actually uh pray the real prayer I'm
not really sure you know if these people
actually know know what prayer really is
they probably haven't you know they're
so far away from reality that she's
yelling about her children literally
she's calling these people her children
and I'm not sure who she's talking I
don't know if she recorded this or this
was like a [ __ ] live stream or some
[ __ ] I have no idea this but but listen
this is the person that people are
listening to for their [ __ ] policy
their politics right this is the reason
why your your Uncle Earl's wives Edna is
all [ __ ] crazy the reason why she
believes all kinds of crazy [ __ ] about
bathrooms and Matt Walsh type genitalia
stuff is because this person in the Q
Anon conspiracy theories is because this
person is the person that they're
looking to for for their guidance let's
keep listening it gets crazier but I
have told you my children I don't need
an election to save your nation I don't
need in another election to bring back
my David I don't need another election
to bring back Revival and my glory and
so my children don't you see that you
have the victory
you did not lose that day no matter what
your enemies say
I gave you the victory you have it it is
yours
so it's time for you to believe this day
which report
why are so many of my children defeated
why are so many believe okay I gotta
stop it I can't I can't like I can't
even put together what the [ __ ] she's
taught she just keeps saying my children
my children my children my children and
I'm not sure if if she um has ever read
like just a book on Cults or not I don't
know I was saying this earlier it feels
like to me
if in Jonestown let's say like half the
people didn't drink the Kool-Aid but
then they walked back to Jonestown and
were like you know what this guy gave
them all the Kool-Aid and they all died
you know let's let's go ahead and try it
or maybe maybe just maybe maybe just
maybe it'll work this time like well
they're like oh well I mean he did give
it to them for free right and wow
technically Jim's Jim Jones gave them
the koi for free Trump is charged them
for the group right right he's the
difference he gives them he gives them
the cup for free or maybe he gives them
the Kool-Aid for free but then he
charged them for the cup or maybe just
all together he's like look if you won
anything like this that's gonna kill you
you got to pay me and they're like oh
yeah I know we got it we we got it we
gotta pay for everything we'll pay you
for the ingredients to make the Kool-Aid
to poison us with
oh my god well just just 2 000 exit if
you would or you know 12 times it or 12
000
um what is what are they saying he says
1200 1200 percent oh twelve hundred
percent yeah just twelve hundred percent
that could impact impact yeah 1200
impact Kool-Aid oh yeah and then with
the Kool-Aid gang says okay speaking of
religious nuts here's another uh Dave uh
50 Shades away I have this
posted and well let's go back I want to
read his tweet here it says a religious
extremists in Pennsylvania showed up to
a school board meeting to try and shove
Christianity into educational curriculum
of course they did a Central Bucks
school district is one of the largest in
the entire State
um this is more of this crazy [ __ ] and I
apologize for the signs of the video but
this is this is what we got to work with
here but just listen to this
absolute bonkers-ass [ __ ] where
they're trying to cram their white
Christian nationalists down our [ __ ]
throat listen let's start by quoting
scripture Proverbs 29 2 when the
righteous are an authority the people
Rejoice but when the wicked when a
wicked man rules the people have grown
this world is God's world and all truth
is God's truth Christianity is and
always has been a part of the common law
this is a Christian Nation and Jesus is
Lord
yet Jesus is the Lord of Education just
as he is the Lord of lords as board
members your Authority is delegated by
the people but ultimately derived from
God no no it's it's not for that stuff
yeah it's not for the white Christian
nationalism look if you want to have a
parochial school I'm not opposed to that
I'm for everyone wanting to be and
having their crazy too fine whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do you want to have
your crazy as long as you're not [ __ ]
negatively affecting other people in the
community go have your crazy somewhere
where you're not doing that and if you
want to have a parochial school where
God controls the school whatever as long
as you're within the bounds of the law
fine whatever the [ __ ] you want to do do
it just you can't press your [ __ ]
and your religion and your beliefs on
anyone else and the reason why you can't
is because that way no one can press
them on you I can't believe well I mean
well I Tony I mean we've seen this again
and again with multiple people from the
right Republican side or even just
people from the religious I mean
typically they are the conservative you
know Evangelical you know Christian type
but they will press their own you know
they will say hey don't don't force you
know your beliefs on me and then they'll
easily say now before school starts or
before this you have to say our father
and Pledge of Allegiance and all this
stuff like I remember having to do that
when I went to Catholic grade school and
and think of the time like this is dumb
why are we doing this right uh but it's
something that you had to do and you got
in trouble if you didn't do
um and now you know you're seeing people
challenge those people to be like what
the [ __ ] you guys doing why are you
forcing that on our children
if it's a private school and you want to
do whatever you want fine but like don't
try to enter this into the public like
ethos for everyone you can't force me as
a parent to let my kid have to listen to
your dumb ass and your dumbass religion
speaking of religious cucks here's the
two biggest religious [ __ ] two guys
that dry up a room instantly just like
that
um now they're going to talk about
religion here and they're going to talk
about it in the context of interracial
and gay marriage all right now yesterday
we watched on the senate floor uh Mitch
McConnell who is in an interracial
marriage voted against protecting
interracial marriage also Tim Scott the
the only black
um the senator Republican senator voted
against interracial marriage as well
um it's it's really [ __ ] weird but
again I was telling the audience earlier
it's not it's not weird when you put it
in the context of authoritarianism
and the reason why is because it's about
their own power is better than yours
right this is the same [ __ ] that they
were just saying at the school board
meeting is I want to press my beliefs on
you but you your beliefs aren't good
enough for me to be pressed on me right
this is the same [ __ ] Mitch McConnell
wants to have his interracial marriage
because he believes it's superior to
yours it's all about superiority and
it's all baked in from white supremacy
and frankly this white Christian
nationalism and here is Ben Shapiro
and Matt Walsh these two [ __ ] Alpha
Cooks talking about Christianity and how
their opposition to gay marriage has
nothing to do with Christianity now
they're saying it's nothing to do with
it listen to this [ __ ] but put aside the
rule of construction the thing that's
really amazing to me is that it is now
apparently the law of the land and
societal rule that the only rationale
that you would possibly have for saying
that a marriage between a man and a
woman is because you're a Christian or a
Jew or a Muslim that's really the only
reason at all that the only reason will
allow you to have these crazy beliefs so
long as you can show that they're crazy
beliefs so long as you can show that the
reason that you believe that marriage is
between a man and a woman is because you
read it in a book and because you really
believe the book they keep saying
sincere religious belief I don't even
know how you measure a sincere religious
belief
I want to point something out does it
look like Matt Walsh is holding in a
fart I mean it really looks like I mean
I don't Matt Walsh Matt Walsh is it's
like a Perpetual thing like he's like oh
my God yeah yeah I mean I the guy is not
happy all right when you have someone
like Matt Walsh obsess over you know 15
16 year old girls and saying how they
should be the ones that get pregnant
you've got him uh trying to prove what a
woman is trying to figure out you know
his own transphobic feelings and whether
the desires or what have you
like
that's a person that lives in a world of
hate
and that hate takes over right you look
like a piece of [ __ ] when you're a
hatred hateful person but Matt Walsh
Matt Walsh does look like right and Matt
Walsh is like I'm kind of holding the
hate right now like that that's all he
does he just he sits and like compresses
his own hatred towards others and then
tries to sound more eloquent and more
sophisticated
oh yeah well and they want to use big
words and more big words he's like when
I don't understand it it sounds satanic
to me anime is satanic to me I don't
really understand what's going on with
anime it's satanic that's I mean that's
literally his argument around I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna argue that anime is
or isn't satanic but there's one thing
for sure is Matt Walsh is a dumb [ __ ]
and his buddy Ben Shapiro here same
category let's yeah let's hear what they
have to say about nature these boneheads
don't understand that like I don't know
there's animals out there that are like
a male and a male and they they have sex
sometimes like homosexuality exist in
the in the uh way way you're telling me
that that exists elsewhere well I mean
here's the thing here's what they're
trying to do here right they lost on
this platform of re or white Christian
nationalism right so they're trying to
slow walk away from that and what we
need to do is not let them do that
[ __ ] because it's not that's not the
truth the truth is they want to press
the religion on us yeah that is what
they want to do now rather you're
religious or not fine whatever that's
the whole point is you get to decide
what your religion is and what it isn't
even if you go to a church a specific
one and you go and you've been a member
for a long time but you highly disagree
with the leadership in that church and
you totally believe a different thing
than they believe I I think you should
have that Liberty to go to the church
and even disagree with the church that
you go to
that you were raised in whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do I mean I could argue
the same thing around if someone were in
a political party if you're fed up with
the way that it's run and you don't
believe that it should be run that way
or you believe the people inside that
party are in fact corrupt right like
maybe right or or even like let's take
Maga in Republicans right and like or
the conservative part of the GOP
and you have people in there like whoa
I'm not a Maga Republican I'm a
Republican and it's like well maybe you
should be affiliated with that party
until they get their [ __ ] together right
or unless you're doing something to
change it but the more and more crazy
people that come into this party and
push this Mega trumpism and it ruins
your vision of what it is
then maybe you shouldn't be affiliated
with it right like if you don't want to
be affiliated with Nazis then maybe
don't sit at a table with them talk to
them associate vote for them right or go
to their America first you know
I just go talk to Nazis I like I mean
I'm not an auntie I just like them get
the [ __ ] out of here let's listen let's
listen to bonehead and bonehead junior
Here work out what they believe it
really gets this closeted type feeling
from these [ __ ] too when they
when they just absolutely they can't
even muster enough courage to I don't
know go talk to someone of the lgbtq
community and actually listen to them
and then develop your beliefs around
what they're telling you about their
reality and their experience I don't
know maybe that's an idea but you know
what do I know
are we gonna like now monitor how often
you go to church or to synagogue whether
you keep kosher or whether you take
communion in order to determine your
sincere I mean the same media that
declares that Nancy Pelosi is a sincere
religious believer who's just for the
mass abortion of unborn children
a little clear that you Matt Walsh are
not actively in in favor of the things
that you're in favor of you're just a
religious bigot you're a bigot right and
your religion is a cover for your
bigotry I'm I'm highly annoyed by the
constant derogation of non-religious
arguments into religious arguments and
this is what the left loves to do they
like to say you're pro-life the reason
you're pro-life is because of your crazy
religion and so maybe we can respect
your crazy religion along those that is
not the argument for marriage the
argument for marriage has literally
nothing to do with religion you could be
an a visitor from from Mars and and you
could see that all of human procreation
relies on man woman child this is not
particularly difficult stuff I
essentially boxing in the argument in
favor okay
our world just passed
eight billion people in population the
other day was it yesterday or the day
before that we did it was the day before
the 8 billion Mark these people act like
these [ __ ] stupid bastards act like
somehow somehow the human race is going
extinct or some [ __ ] because women
aren't [ __ ] men enough well we are
going extinct by the issue of world
population right right well I mean the
world the world is gonna snuff us right
exactly like we are going to go extinct
because of uh famine climate change uh
consuming uh
you know Pro a mass consumption of
produce and
um you know we did these are just things
that
we have an issue that we have we have
brought into the world because we have
overpopulated the world and we cannot
Escape like the world is only so big
it's a finite amount of space and if we
are over the last 10 years we went from
7 billion to 8 billion right like over
that decade
maybe it's something that we want to
reconsider and say like hey guys we
can't really scale this way and there's
no way any time close to right now that
we're going to be on the moon or Mars in
terms of inhabiting this in a larger
population and also the people that are
going to be able to go to those places
are the [ __ ] rich people that have
already been trying to get them well
they got you got [ __ ] Bezos with his
blue balls spaceship you got Elon with
his SpaceX I run
yeah it's
it's dumb like this idea that we need to
we need to
be married or we need to have more
children it really doesn't seem to be
solving the problem that we have right
now which is war famine Strife like all
these things
you put more people in a [ __ ] box
that's already hot enough like people
are going to get more agitated more
Angry for them to say for for benjamir
to say that oh people are just accusing
you of being a religious bigot my guess
is that Matt Walsh and Ben Shapiro are
bigots and they just use their religion
as the shield that's what actually
happens it's not their religion that
makes them a bigot
necessarily they use that as a shield
and and fake Gabe listen man I love
Avenue here and I love your stupid
comments so I can bring them up and
knock them out of the park but don't
tell me what they said when we just
[ __ ] listen to it if you want to do
commentary if you want to do your own
comment I'm I'm more than happy to
[ __ ] set you up on a tee and knock
you out of the park but if you want to
do it I called I called fake Gabe
yesterday he never answered the phone he
didn't answer okay so he just sent me
straight to voicemail ah poor guy listen
if you want to do your own commentary
that's cool go get your own [ __ ] show
but we all listen to what the hell they
just said everyone heard it here there's
I don't know there's 1500 people
watching right now
and and they all heard what they said so
[ __ ] off or give us a comment that I
could bring up and and he says he wants
to meet me face to face oh wow you can
um come to L.A I know that you're not
too far from where I live you told me I
know what city you live in you can
easily drive in my direction we'll meet
up at a park and we'll live stream the
show
yeah [ __ ] fake game easy easy on the
easy on the thin veil threats there
buddy okay so let's let's finish let's
let fate Gabe listen to the words that
are coming out of these chuckleheads
mouth because I'm sure Matt Walsh has
something brilliant to say even
traditional marriage into well if you're
a crazy religious believer maybe we'll
let you have that but you know if you're
baking it if you're a cake baker then
we're not sure about that right I mean
like we're not sure how far this this
religious liberty thing extends what
you're really doing is you're setting
the ground game at same-sex marriage and
traditional marriage are completely the
same thing and if you object to it the
only reason that we'll even allow you to
do that is because of this crazy thing
called they are the same they are the
same they're the same they're the
[ __ ] same how is it any different
it's different because you believe that
it's different but you don't have to get
gay marriage you don't have to do it no
one's forcing you that's that's called
uh the [ __ ] Liberty that's the [ __ ]
word right if you want to get straight
married cool Ben Shapiro if you want to
marry your wife and never get her [ __ ]
wet do it man that is your Liberty that
is your Liberty to do in this country
you have the free right to marry your
wife and not understand what a whop is
and then get confused you know again it
go really goes back to they have this
desire
to
experience those things we'll say right
they want to go to the drag show they
want to be touched by a man or someone
from the lgbtq community I I honestly
think that they their worst nightmare is
actually their best dream
I think that they actually want to
experience
how because you really got to think
about this like where does that come
from there is an un
necessary hatred toward a group of
people who didn't know who you were
never spoke to you never had any sort of
uh
uh desire to ever see you
that you want to force these things on
them right but you're projecting that
they're forcing things on you they don't
even know who the [ __ ] you are they
don't even care who the [ __ ] they are
you are they're in their home doing
their own thing just like you're in your
home not getting your wife [ __ ] wet
right so at the end of the day like as
much as they would probably help you get
your wife off
maybe you can shut the [ __ ] up and mind
your own business and do your own thing
I don't know I mean like what's the
whole idea of like you know you are the
master of your own domain you're
probably not the master of your own
domain but don't try to do that to other
people don't try to enter their home
and and and and and and
impart your beliefs
and try to break their privacy and their
their religious freedom their bodily
freedom
that at least they have right now
but that's what they want to do they
have this on on this [ __ ] weird
bizarre desire they're weirdos they're
weird I mean honestly honestly it
reminds me of [ __ ] handmaid's tale
right you've got that one person in the
corner of the room who's like monitoring
the [ __ ] sex that happens you got the
other person it's like
holding the woman then you've also got
the the man that's forcing himself on
the woman that's really is just the the
Earthen vessel that they they think
about it seems [ __ ] weird man it
seems like it seems like they watch too
many [ __ ] TV shows and think they're
real just like just like fake gabeer
here this is what I need you for buddy
this is what you have to do this is this
is what your your job is in the chat
fake Gabe this is your job to be the
Trump copy machine okay keep doing this
he says apparently
these two have never seen teachers
teaching young children about sex listen
man I I know that you're probably
getting a lot of sexual feelings that
are suppressed because you never
actually got educated on on [ __ ] what
sex is you understand you understand
what Ben Shapiro and Matt Walsh are
saying is oh this is all nature it's man
woman child it's Nature Nature Nature
yet you [ __ ] don't want to
learn about nature because oh it might
just make me gay oh my God it might gave
me up it might it might make me get all
kinds of weird feelings inside listen
there is sex education it is a thing it
is a thing that people need to [ __ ]
know about I don't know if you've heard
of sexually transmitted diseases or not
I don't know if you've heard about I
don't know certain types of cancer or
not that happen and I don't know the the
regions that you can't talk about fake
Gabe listen there is there is sex
education it is a thing and we must
educate people on on it not not because
they need to know about sex but because
they need to know the [ __ ] and the facts
even if you're scared of them it's okay
that you're scared of them and you think
it's gonna like change also education
also sex education if for anyone who
isn't clear right happens during a time
when you are developing right you're
going through puberty you're 13 you know
seventh eighth grade and then obviously
you enter into high school and you learn
uh more about that yeah so you're saying
you're saying that that this education
is delivered at a time I mean really
what it is it's health class like you're
learning about how the body works right
no one's trying to look at myself right
no one no one's saying look at this
diagram of a a vagina like that's gonna
make you a lesbian or look at this
diagram of a penis that's going to make
you gay that is not how that works
that's probably what Vic gave scared of
he's like wow
right I was in high school and they were
putting condoms on bananas and it it got
me a a boner I mean that boner made me
feel weird inside because I was watching
a dude put a condom on a banana and it
really made me feel all kinds of worn
feelings down in my nether regions I
don't I mean you know they give you a
problem that's your [ __ ] problem it's
a it's a health class and in that health
class there's a topic that covers sex
education right right safe sex uh STDs
or I think they're now called STIs you
know all of these things that deal with
your your body your health right there's
also a biology class that really goes
into the in-depth aspects of it like on
a cellular level right probably over
your head no easy easy on the science
easy on the science but I will say that
really at the end of the day those
things are not taught to like a second
grader or a third grader or fourth
grader like you're not you're not
getting this until you're developing
right to say oh [ __ ] there's things
happen in my body and these are going to
answer some of these questions right the
thing the thing that you're saying I
gave about the the educating young
children is just as [ __ ] [ __ ] as
cat litter boxes in the [ __ ] hallways
uh mighty librarian points out here she
said I went to a very Progressive school
we didn't have one girl get pregnant or
at least carry the term
they were very Progressive in teaching
about how your body worked and the
consequences of sex that's the whole
point dummies is that if you don't know
you don't know if you're ignorant of
what happens even though I don't know
you got these urges to do these things
but you don't know what they are and you
don't know the consequences of them
you're gonna I don't know [ __ ] up so the
point is is to educate people on what
this stuff is and it really again Vicky
I appreciate because this is your job
this is what you're supposed to do
you're supposed to put them up on the
tee so we can knock them out of the park
also I just really like the idea that
fate Gabe was in his health class or his
you know learning about sex education
saw a diagram of a flaccid penis I
literally just like anatomical diagram
and he was like oh that makes me feel
all sorts of things that's not how that
works
get a bucket and a mop for this strong
fake Gabe is just afraid that when
you're educated then you become gay or
something like it's a weird logic that
fake gay passes kind of weird Okay so
fake Gabe um why we're talking about
this go get your get your links ready
for your Hunter Biden's laptop [ __ ]
you're gonna need them here buddy we're
gonna go to the hunter button lamp top
[ __ ] so go get your Links at you're
gonna need that list of them uh on Uncle
Earl's Facebook page
um so here is
the Republicans announcing that they're
gonna do the thing that they said
they're gonna do even though American
people basically told them don't do that
that's dumb
and they're going to investigate lamb
top and they're going to say the word
laptop as many laptop signs as they can
say lamped up and probably in this
laptop Congress Gabe I would imagine
that a laptop is going to be laptop
talked about a laptop lot now if this
said laptop actually comes to fruition
and we find this laptop I would bet that
this laptop is really sad about being a
laptop that these people are pointing
out that it's a laptop and that there
aren't very many laptop people that have
laptops in this laptop world that we
live in laptop laptop laptop I mean it's
it's gonna be dude I'm telling you this
is what it's gonna sound like like it is
gonna sound every other word will be
laptop I would you know what I I want to
challenge anyone out there uh when they
do bring this forward because they have
the majority now with 218. when they
bring this forward and everyone's gonna
have their own thing because they all
want their 15 minutes of of Fame on Fox
news or or wherever they're going to be
on right I want someone for the period
of time you know what specifically on
the house floor when they bring this
forward right or they set up their
committee or whatever how many times
laptop is mentioned in relation to
everything else like I want to know is
it going to be greater than 50 percent
or less than 50 and the ratio of laptop
to all other words right well you know I
was talking about this earlier is that
the the ratio between the word that they
used to love the most deficit you
remember this are dead oh yeah dead
deficit
listen we got a deficit that we gotta
handle in this deficit country and the
deficit is going to be the most deficit
thing that we actually deficit in this
in this new deficit Congress I mean
that's the way it used to be right like
Memphis and deficit deficit deficit
that's national debt National and had a
few replacement words there but now
laptop let's listen to what the big
announcement is on Hunter Biden's laptop
let's listen City report or SAR is a
document a bank must file with the
treasury Department when a transaction
is suspected to be related to money
laundering or fraud or other types of
criminal activity
according to Media report the Biden
family accumulated over 150 SARS
one SAR generated by an American Bank of
the Treasury Department connects Hunter
Biden and his business associates to
international human trafficking
among other illegal activities the money
that was being made from foreign
principals in the same room as Joe Biden
was increasingly spent on furthering
illegal activity the Tsar show that
Hunter Biden was conducting business
with suspected human traffickers
okay so more projecting more nonsense
more q and on [ __ ] and again I think
Gabe put your links to your [ __ ] Q
Anon stuff in in the chat here I'm sure
everyone will go look at them or oink
um but here's the thing here's the thing
is that literally none of that is true
none of that is real none of it yeah the
thing that they're trying to do this
morning though then I noticed that's a
little different
is they're trying to say that Hunter
Biden's laptop is like 50 owned by Joe
Biden like he kind of owned it well I
guess like if you're thinking of like
the transit of property right Joe Biden
right conceived right Hunter Biden right
so if it's Hunter Biden's laptop then it
has to be 50 makeup of Hunter Biden
means 50 ownership okay by Joe Biden
this makes sense so like in some kind of
states rights [ __ ] mind [ __ ] they're
giving they're giving um parental
ownership to something that someone
um else I do really enjoy the fact that
they're bringing up like here's thing if
you guys want to investigate Hunter
Biden go the [ __ ] right ahead he always
been stopping actually actually the
thing is they have been investigating
him they have been and that is that is
true yeah and they came to a deal about
the [ __ ] taxes that he didn't pay and
they're gonna find him for it likely
that is going to be the punishment he's
going to receive because that's the
thing that they can prove and the reason
why is because you [ __ ] idiots
totally [ __ ] towards the idea that
you were gonna ever investigate this
laptop when you tainted it over and over
and over and over again instead of just
letting I don't know law enforcement do
their [ __ ] job here is a prime
example of what more sh [ __ ] we're
gonna listen to Ron Johnson has the
chance to ask Christopher Ray the FBI
director anything he [ __ ] wants to
anything he wants to right now in this
moment
in time and he decides to ask him this
like I take compliance with all of our
other rules very soon
um Senator Grassley wrote you a letter
on July 25th 2020.
in which he said that whistleblowers his
office
uh reported that FBI officials initiated
a scheme to downplay derogatory
information on Hunter Biden for the
purpose of shutting down respiratory
activity related to his potential
criminal exposure by labeling it quote
disinformation but that's a that's a
familiar term uh that scheme would be to
you you [ __ ]
uh also included you said in August 2020
FBI supervisor supervisor intelligence
analyst Brian auten opened an assessment
which was used by FBI headquarters team
to improperly discredit negative Hunter
Biden information is disinformation and
cause investigative activity to cease
have you responded to Senator grassley's
letter that he wrote over three months
ago
uh Senator I know there have been a
whole slew of letters I believe we've
responded to a number of them but I
sitting here right now
have you looked into those charges that
there was a scheme hatched okay and I'm
not gonna this is the [ __ ] that's gonna
happen it's gonna continue to happen
right it's not going to stop also it's
it when you're when you're asking
someone the specificity of like hey did
you answer all these letters it's like
dude I'm not in charge of answering
these [ __ ] letters I won the FBI the
other the other thing too is that really
truly if if Ron Johnson had the
investigation into Hunter Biden's laptop
at the Forefront of his mind then what
he would do and if it has to do with sex
traffic and money laundering and all
kinds of crazy ass International
[ __ ] that pulls in them present in
the United States it's impeachable
charges you would do it in a [ __ ]
setting where you could ask those
questions that he could answer right
instead of wasting the American people's
time of watching you ask a question and
that the [ __ ] can't answer
because what what happens is is
Christopher Ray says what Christopher
way will always say is look even if
there's an investigation we're not going
to confirm or denial right you know that
you know that [ __ ] sitting right here
why would you even go down right well
the reason they asked the question is
because they need that response to then
use and say well they wouldn't answer it
right like fake Gabe and other people
will probably say oh well they're
suppressant it's like literally any
investigation you ask anything that is
somehow connected to something else and
they don't know what's going on or just
to be safe they're like look I cannot
comment on this whether it is happening
or it's not happening because if I
comment on it then it makes it possibly
worse than what it is right you know a
good example of this is um there was a
lady who ran for president I forget what
her [ __ ] name was she had some some
kind of email problem I don't know it
really didn't think yeah that's it
Hillary Clinton they didn't the email
lady they did not like her emails and
they were investigating her this is the
other thing they were the FBI was
investigating Hillary Clinton a former
first lady former person who resided in
the White House who was running for
president they were investigating her
now when they came out and they made
that stupid statement and then when he
rewrote the letter you can see what kind
of Havoc it can cause it can cause a
[ __ ] ton of Havoc because you just don't
know what the response is going to be so
just keep your [ __ ] mouth shut and
when you decide to criminally charge
someone criminally charge them that's
why I've continued to say that Trump is
[ __ ] and and you you out there
bitching that he isn't charged yet
listen when he is charged maybe you can
say well maybe I was wrong maybe I was
wrong because you are because they're
not going to show their cards that's why
Trump is freaking out and he's trying to
get the doj to show their cards on the
documents case is because they won't do
it
um
there's a I I want to go we we had um
because we're we're getting to
um we're almost 15 minutes till the end
of the show here
um I do want to say because Brittany
Greiner is trending and I'm not sure if
this has to do with the uh the talk of
the missiles that were launched into
Poland now apparently these were not
Russian missiles and we were really
trying to look for because this happened
live on the air the other day
um we were really trying to look for
what that what the reporting was at
first it was thought that those were two
Russian missiles
um now we know that they were two
um anti-missiles that were launched uh
against Russian missiles that had been
battering
um actual residential places and
Commercial places in Ukraine
um because Russia's down to just the
dumb bombs at this point it seems like
so yeah
um Ukraine's trying to use whatever
um tactical way they can with uh
anti-missile missiles and on
unfortunately two of them went into
Poland and but Brittany Brittany
greiner's name came up
um because Article 5 kind of got floated
around now now that I think they invoked
article four but not they're not going
to invoke Article 5 because it was not a
Russian assault but
um her names have come up and people are
reporting uh let's see Philip Lewis has
something here let's see what he's got
here and Brittany Greiner has reportedly
been taking into Pinot colony in the
Russian region mordova Russian
authorities have given no information or
whereabouts for nearly two weeks so this
is on par for the Russian government
yeah um even they did the same thing
with navaldi do you remember this Gabe
when navaldi came back from being
poisoned he went to Germany recovered he
was actually able to stay alive which is
remarkable and then he he bravely
said I don't give a [ __ ] I'm going back
to Russia and they arrested him
immediately
um and then and they kind of did the
same thing to navaldi and it looks like
they're going to do the same thing to
Brittany granner but I didn't I I went
into the straight because I didn't know
if her name came up because of this this
uh missile thing I know it did the other
day but it looks like they have not
heard from Brittany Greiner which should
really piss Americans off and it really
is something to watch an entire party be
for Putin here yeah I mean it is sad to
see like you know obviously the
situation is pretty shitty in terms of
like going to getting jailed for that
but also the fact that there's just no
transparency and in a foreign country
saying yep we took that person and we're
not gonna give you an update on who it
is like
say what you want about Ukraine versus
you know Russia and whatever your
[ __ ] dumb belief about
colonizing one area over the other
because you're [ __ ] next door
neighbors to it
forget that [ __ ] for a second if you
really are pro-life right and you really
do believe
in the life
of of your fellow American
then you would care for the quality of
life that she gets right that that
Britney has you would care to know like
oh [ __ ] is this person missing like
what's going on I mean obviously we know
that they don't because you see people
like uh
Don Jr right Donald Trump Jr making
jokes about Brittany Greiner when she
originally got arrested and caught
he was making jokes about that he was
making light of it just the same way is
the point right right exactly the same
way that he was joking about you know
Paul Pelosi getting hit with a hammer in
his head and talking about how it was
some gay guy that came into the house
which again was debunked not true and
really goes to show again that when you
don't have an argument about oh [ __ ] we
should actually condemn this you tried
to subvert it by saying oh well it's
something gay or it's something uh from
something trans or whatever it might be
right like that's the immediate go-to
when you've got a party that doesn't
have an actual like Counterpoint then
they just start attacking you on a
personal level and that was the joke it
was Candace Owens all these people were
were pushing this idea and that's all
they do right that's all they do and
you'll see it again and again and again
Hunter Biden's laptop or whatever the
[ __ ] they want to complain about well
I'll tell you I'll tell you what they're
going to complain about because it looks
like um
we we noticed in the last few days that
Marjorie Taylor green she became a rhino
and decided to link up arms with Kevin
McCarthy in his supporters amazing how
yeah how quickly those things happened
she was she complained about rhinos and
now she's a rhino right it looks like um
Brian Tyler Cohen has uh some of the
scoop here it appears that Kevin
McCarthy secured her vote for speaker by
promising to start a quote investigation
oh my God here we go
of how violent January 6
insurrectionists are being mistreated
uh Marjorie Taylor Greene has Kevin
McCarthy on a leash uh Brian says here
now
um this would be the assumption that the
people who are being tried and jailed
um for their acts of the Insurrection
rather it be um the like the organizers
or Oath Keepers proud boys
um and some of these fake State electors
scheme that we're probably going to see
some indictments on soon but the actual
violent ones the ones that were breaking
Windows smearing [ __ ] right um they were
stealing things from our bills which is
a weird look I'm just gonna call I'm
just gonna call it what it is like
smearing [ __ ] on the capital that's a
weird Flex man that's a weird thing to
be like yeah I [ __ ] came in there and
I sneered [ __ ] all over Nancy Plus's
offense it's like but you'd have to
don't I mean how could you'd have to
[ __ ] in your hand right like I'm trying
to figure out you don't I don't know I
mean I get [ __ ] on the floor
you got to pick it up like either way
you didn't wipe you had to get it you
wiped you wiped well now on the wall for
sure but like if I had those things
where it's like when you're really I
mean you don't really need much time to
stop and really think about the [ __ ]
up thing you did you decided to smear
[ __ ] on the walls like is that why
they're calling them a gagging now yeah
it might be I mean they uh that's a
weird [ __ ] thing it's uh they're
they're [ __ ] weird they're like
obsessed with genitalia and bathrooms or
smearing [ __ ] on the walls and public
buildings they've got weird obsessions
nothing here let's see
nothing nothing that is actually that
they're obsessed about is for Americans
to help the American people everything
else is just a distraction yeah it's
just it's just a bunch of
um
like it's the way that I look at it is
like junk food politics yeah well it's
the intersection of WrestleMania in real
life and and like Al Franken says here
he's trending right now because of this
he they're chicken shits okay here's
what he says here's what Al Franken
tweets which um if you guys don't know
who Al Franken is yeah you need to go do
your own research but
um here's the thing Al Franken should
still be United States Senator but um he
tweets here about Kevin McCarthy and he
congratulates him which you know he
wants to congratulate Kevin I'm sure Al
Frank let me read it cat get Al Franken
says congratulations to the horrible
lying scumbag Kevin McCarthy on winning
the nomination to lead to terrible group
compromised almost entirely of nut
um copper might prize excuse me almost
entirely of net jobs and or chicken
shits so
um I might add Traders in there too but
you know I would definitely say treaters
but you know what a great
congratulations I mean you know Kevin
McCarthy should probably print this out
and hang it on the wall yeah I mean he
said congrats that's a nice thing yeah
congratulations from Alvin oh yeah why
not any any acknowledgment from Al
Franken would be nice absolutely and for
Kevin McCarthy the little cush bag that
he is yeah you know yeah he says he's
lying he says horrible lying scumbag
that's a cuck bag but that's fine uh you
know I think it's it's all you know I
take his and I just like compile it into
cuck bag and I think that you know
good for good for Kevin McCarthy you
know doing nothing to help Americans
only to help himself
um you know he's gonna probably be on
the you know he'll be on the floor at
some point uh crying with his little
khaki pants trying to filibuster and he
tries to do the John Boehner thing
doesn't he because you know him and John
Boehner were good buddies right they
would they would apparently drink brandy
and smoke cigars together or some [ __ ]
and John Boehner absolutely [ __ ]
despised Donald Trump thinks he's a dumb
[ __ ] by the way we should check in on
the 2024 Donald Trump campaign make sure
that thing's still rolling oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah we should really it's
trickling yeah okay good at least it's
still around
um but um you know Kevin McCarthy and
John Boehner were really good friends if
no one is aware of who John Boehner is
John Boehner is the guy
oh I Cry
just did the thought of the the floor of
the bar that he used to have to sweep he
he does this story where he sweeps the
the floor of the bar that his dad owned
or some [ __ ] yeah and he just starts
just [ __ ] the Waterworks command on
John Boehner right yeah and then him and
him and Kevin McCarthy were good friends
and Kevin McCarthy was really excited
about being the speaker of the house if
you remember way back when and he went
on TV and he's like yeah remember that
Benghazi hearing that was to politically
damage Hillary Clinton and look where
we're at we politically damaged her and
then here they are literally just years
later he's gonna possibly have the
ability to become the speaker again and
they're running on and and talking about
how they're going to run investigations
just to politically damage right Joe
Biden but in many ways you might think
that that actually didn't work out so
well because when you look at it in 2020
hindsight you compare Hillary Clinton
yeah and how she went forward with the
Benghazi investigation and also the 2016
election and what she said about Trump
and you look at that and you say oh
actually turns out Trump was someone who
was uh you know working or you know
helping Putin and willing to sell out
the American uh our country you know on
for the for a dollar right the guy stole
government secrets and documents and
nuclear secrets about other places damn
it yeah
I don't know right because they could be
I'm sure if he used his mind control
listen this is all really stupid [ __ ]
because the thing is there is no Hunter
Biden's laptop there is no [ __ ] Also
let's talk I mean you brought something
up earlier too about how tainted it was
if you're gonna have a laptop and you
say let's say paint yes taint oh okay
okay good I said tainted just tainted if
you were like Hey look I have a laptop
and the owner was Hunter Biden and it's
got all the stuff on it which should
absolutely be illegal for a hunter Biden
to own a lamped up right exactly but if
you said look at this laptop I have it
open it up look at these photos these
videos great okay cool
well you're now making these accusations
about human trafficking and this and
that and whatever
if you did have this evidence okay it's
wild stuff you give it to the FBI yeah
or you you give it to what you would
probably want to give it to someone who
could prosecute someone for those crimes
that you're saying right right but also
you have to remember that this [ __ ] has
been passed around on a goddamn thumb
drive
for months now I think when you remember
the Matt gatz moment when he's right
he's like he's like I got he's like I
got in a record on on this thumb drive
I'm using the hand here I've got all of
Hunter Biden's content of his laptop on
this thumb drive right okay man thunder
thumb drive right here
hold on wait wait do you pull the thumb
out and that's right you pull it out and
it's got a little thing and it goes
right in and then
that's actually a pretty good idea yeah
probably don't steal it you [ __ ] yeah
so I have to say that moment where Matt
Gates is in there he's like I'd like to
enter this into evidence they're like
what the [ __ ] is that he goes it's the
contents of Hunter Biden's laptop and
you're like dude first off why would you
put it into this committee two if you
really did have the evidence we don't
know where the [ __ ] that thumb drive
came from how many ports you plugged it
into in and out and in and out how many
things you took advantage of and how
many things are real and not real like
that's something you might want to make
sure that you give over to the
authorities and when they do have it the
great thing about the FBI and whoever
else has it is they have people who are
specialized
in the digital fingerprint
that is left by where this [ __ ] comes
from
I just want to say that the idea of
having a hand with the thumb is a thumb
drive that seems really handy it would
be handy to have a thumb drive in the
hand oh my God Jesus Christ listen there
is no Hunter Biden's laptop that's all
nonsense it's all [ __ ] and that's
why they're talking about it just like
they talked about Joe Biden is
controlling gas prices and that you
should be scared of other people's
genitalia inside bathrooms and CRT in
schools it's all nonsense it's all
[ __ ] it doesn't really exist it only
exists in their [ __ ] minds in their
[ __ ] non-reality reality that they
[ __ ] live in yeah it's not a thing
man oh you know what I have breaking
news I have breaking news
um Hunter Hunter Biden's laptop is
releasing a statement right now and 100
binds limestop is going to be doing a
press conference oh to talk about how
full of [ __ ] the House Republicans truly
are I mean this is this is literally the
road that we're going down and the thing
is is we should mock them at every turn
folks because this Hunter Biden's laptop
thing as much as everyone's gonna be
like I'm sick of hearing about it that's
what we should we should literally make
sure the narrative in this country is
are you sick a hunter Biden's laptop doc
yet right are you ready to open the
government back up and start doing some
[ __ ] are you ready to start doing that
because folks as much as we don't want
to talk about Hunter binds laptop it's
time for us to lean into the idea that
yes it's dumb it's stupid and why are
they talking about it it's gonna make
them look like fools so what's let's not
take the shovel out of the Nazis hands
when they're [ __ ] digging their own
grave do not take the matter of fact
let's give them a big huge [ __ ]
backhoe and let them dig that some
[ __ ] deep and as efficient as they
[ __ ] can because we can't we cannot
we cannot tuck tail and run from
democracy and these fools are going to
do everything they can
to show right out in the open that they
have not only do they not believe in
democracy but they have no [ __ ] clue
how to run one they don't [ __ ] know
it's not a thing that they know they
just don't like Jim Jordan Jim I don't
report sex guns Jordan this guy is going
to be the of course he was the um that
the guy on our thumbnail today because
he's one of the world's worst that um
well this is also I mean like the guy
that's obsessed with the the
um
the gross contents of Hunter Biden's
laptop is also the guy that was like
what sexual misconduct and mistreatment
of Stu of of wrestlers by the by the
coach in the in the doctor no that never
happened that never happened I don't
know why I gave him that voice but
that's Jim Jordan's voice right now and
and I said this earlier get a [ __ ]
coat man even John fetterman even John
fetterman went to the hill and put a
[ __ ] coat on dude you was like one of
the people that complained about
President Obama in the Oval Office take
God forbid the guy who's running the
[ __ ] country says oh man shit's kind
of crazy I'm gonna take my joke I'm
gonna I'm gonna take my jacket off
you're joking I joke it yeah yeah I'm
gonna take that thing it's been a long
time has a joke it uh because he's a
[ __ ] joke but God forbid President
Obama after a long day of trying to help
Americans whether he's passing the
American Health Care Act or trying to
save the Auto industry or whatever it
might be sits down in the chair and says
man got to take this coat off I gotta
roll my sleeves it's gonna be a long
night guys we're gonna pull an
all-nighter we're going to try and find
some sort of idea on how we can work
together in the house and the Senate
like let's let's do something and people
[ __ ] blew up and they're like oh my
God he just ruined the sanctity of the
Oval Office because he took off the
jacket right these are all the same
people that got really upset when he
wore a tan suit are you he wanted Dijon
mustard okay yeah so here Benny Johnson
posted this video that tells you
anything about it um Benny Johnson is
one of the guy that was like uh he was
like [ __ ] he was with Charlie Kirk
when Kerry Lake was oh crashing and
burning and they were like we're in an
echo chamber maybe yeah dummy
um so he posted this video and he thinks
this is a huge Flex like they're posting
this stuff like yeah woohoo they're
gonna investigate the laptop listen to
to Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
who doesn't is the only [ __ ]
without a coat on up there let's listen
get me up so I would just start with
this question what part of Mr Comer's
presentation was Russian disinformation
we never forget what happened on October
19th 2020 15 days before the most
important election we have in our
country who's going to be the next
president United States 15 days before
that Mr Brennan Mr Clapper and 49 other
people signed a letter that said the
following it is for these reasons that
we write to say that the arrival on the
U.S political scene of emails
purportedly belonging to vice president
Vice President Biden's son Hunter has
all the classic earmarks of a Russian
information operation
they further went on to say we want to
emphasize that we did not know if the
email is provided to the New York posts
are genuine or not just that our
experience makes us deeply suspicious
that the Russian government played a
significant role in this case okay this
is a really weird flex and we gotta go
and here's why it's a really weird Flex
because he is literally literally sang
okay that the Trump Administration for
four [ __ ] years ignored this
information this stupid [ __ ]
they literally had the house the Senate
the presidency for two years and they
ignored the information that he sang was
so important this is a really stupid
flex and the reason why they they did
never gave a [ __ ] about Hunter Biden and
his laptop until Joe Biden was going to
kick Trump's ass is because there was no
reason to until he was gonna [ __ ]
bury Trump under mountains of votes
that's why that's why only now and only
when Joe Biden ran were they concerned
about that [ __ ] laptop you
[ __ ] were not concerned about
Hunter Biden or any any kind of [ __ ]
electronic devices that he had in the
first two years that you had the house
the Senate and the presidency you dumb
[ __ ] and this is a weird Flex
that you would stand there and go oh we
knew this information back in 2016.
[ __ ] Brennan and Clapper and they
told us and blah blah blah and we did
nothing about it oh but now you're going
to do something about it yeah it seems
kind of suspicious I'm just saying I'm
just saying they gave them get us a link
of why I'm wrong it's hurry up because
we're getting we're getting close on
time yeah man it is
it never gets old I mean well it does
get old yeah it's gonna get old and
we're gonna make sure it gets old that's
the point right yeah that's the point is
we have to make this nonsense this
[ __ ] just old that's why people went
and voted against these [ __ ]
like Kerry Lake they're tired of you
talking about 20 20. they're tired of it
they're tired of you bro dude that was
three elections ago like literally I
believe in 2020 or 2056 they'll still be
like 2020 was stolen it was and everyone
since then stolen like that's the thing
so we gotta make people tired of this
[ __ ] the only way the only way not to
hear about this [ __ ] are to [ __ ]
litigate this [ __ ] or continue to talk
about this nonsense is to vote them the
[ __ ] out well we got two [ __ ]
years until we can do that so we gotta
lean into it we got to make sure the
American people are tired of the
trumpism tired of the laptop talk and we
got to [ __ ] bury these son of a
[ __ ] and the next one because I told
you 2020 is the most important election
of our democracy's lifetime and now that
that sumbitch is so close to being
counted and over
2022. what did I say 22 2020. what 2020
was and then 2022 now now that we got
them all counted
2024. see I even get these elections
confused because they're confused it
happens it happens everyone same time
same place tomorrow you know tomorrow
you know what tomorrow is game it's
Friday it's Friday Friday Friday Friday
you know what happens on Friday bonan of
the week and the second half of the week
so be looking for the bone Hen of the
week poll you can vote for bonehead of
the week right here on YouTube don't
forget to subscribe go to the community
tab you'll find that that poll sometime
this evening also you can go to Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod as long as Twitter
is still around it's still ticking over
there they're still bandaging it
together I feel like Elon just like
pulling levers on his own you know he's
pushing buttons trying to make things
work yeah well it's kind of I guess I I
got some news about Elon but I'll share
it tomorrow okay great great great great
and then download every single episode
of the Tony Michaels podcast on the
Apple Spotify Google and go to the merch
store
go to the merch store head over there
and grab your store and not meet
donniemichaels.com grab your Rhonda
Santa skin go [ __ ] himself that's stored
not the Tony michaels.com also these
things are still flying off the shelves
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people it's not Liberty and again
this goes right into this [ __ ] that
we watched yesterday of Mitch McConnell
voting against the the codifying and
protection of interracial marriage when
he is in one the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty go
grab your hoodies today it's getting
cold outside everyone I want to make one
more announcement before we go Gabe um
this will be the bonehead of the week
this week will be they'll We're not
gonna have one next week because it's
Thanksgiving thank you so we'll be off
I'm gonna I want to reiterate that a
couple times we'll be off Thursday and
Friday next week we're not gonna have
shows and we're not We're Not Gonna post
anything I just decided I don't think
we're gonna post anything we're going to
give you guys the day off we'll have the
day off enjoy your families in the
holiday we will be back Monday Tuesday
Wednesday of next week but this week
will be the last bonehead for a couple
weeks okay so make sure to be here
tomorrow to see the bonehead of the week
or go to the minus touch Facebook page
and catch the shortened version over
there who wins everyone same time same
place tomorrow YouTube Twitter twitch
might just touch Facebook page our
Facebook page Newton Eastern 11 Central
9 Pacific until tomorrow Surfside
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon